This video is made possible by Nord VPN. If you are online,
you really must be using a VPN. And that's where Nord VPN come.
In.
It's tempting not to bother and hope for the best,
but really those stories you read about people having their data stolen do
happen. And you don't want to make it that easy for anyone to do that.
But using a VPN offers more than just security, for example,
nor VPN lets you access any of its thousands of servers in different countries
around the globe. So if you've hit the end of your Netflix queue,
simply try changing the location of your server and get access to content
libraries that due to licensing agreements are only available in specific
geographic locations. For example,
most European countries have strong licensing agreements restricting which
soccer matches can be viewed depending on the location of the viewer with Nord
VPN, you can change your country without even moving from your sofa.
Nord VPN is super fast. So watching a video is a breeze, no lag whatsoever.
If you've ever used VPNs and thought they were slow. Well,
no more with Nord VPN and you can use it on all your devices. Very, very easily.
Android Chrome windows, Linux, and on up to six different devices.
One account also, there are no logs kept at all.
Unlike companies based in the EU or us Nord VPN is based in Panama,
so they don't have to keep logs all great for your privacy.
So take control of your internet experience right now,
go to Nord vpn.com forward slash visual politic and use the code visual politic
to get 70% off a three-year plan with an extra month thrown in for free.
And now let's get into it.
[Inaudible].
In 2020,
almost every country in the world is going to suffer a huge recession from the
pandemic of the new SaaS coronavirus to where all of them struggle. No,
there is a select club of countries that in principle will benefit and
everything indicates that the biggest winner of this pandemic is going to be
none other than Vietnam.
I know the first word that comes to your mind when you hear Vietnam is war the
Vietnam war in the 1960s,
thousands of young Americans left at this country with their military boots and
rifles. But the story has an ironic twist because now 65 years after all that,
the grandchildren of those young people are returning to Vietnam.
Although this time they are dressed in ties and armed with tablets and laptops.
Yes, friends of visual politic Vietnam is on trend. We could say.
It's the new China.
In fact.
Many companies that had factories in China already moving much of their business
to Vietnam. This process was already happening before the coronavirus hit,
but the pandemic has accelerated this trend and we're not talking about small
businesses, either.
Samsung shifts some smartphone production to Vietnam due to coronavirus.
And yes,
much of this change is because Vietnam has been one of these countries that have
best managed the pandemic. That's right here on this channel,
we have detailed how countries such as South Korea, Taiwan,
or the Czech Republic could be used as examples of how to manage the pandemic.
Perhaps you haven't heard about Vietnam's progress,
but the truth is they've done surprisingly well.
We're talking about a relatively poor country.
We have more than 95 million inhabitants that shares a border with China.
So how many deaths would you say they've had?
Well, the answer.
Is zero. Exactly. At the time we're making this video,
Vietnam has not had any deaths from COVID-19. What's more,
one of the videos the government has released about public health information
has gone viral and no wonder people look.
[Inaudible].
But this whole story goes far beyond the coronavirus.
Vietnam has been growing and attracting companies for decades. In fact,
here's a very curious fact. Vietnam is a communist dictatorship,
much like China. However,
Vietnamese society is a supporter of the free market in the world.
At least that's what a Pew research center survey carried out in 2015 sets.
And it makes a lot of sense more and more companies are setting up in Vietnam
furniture, clothing, shoe factories, to give you an idea.
One out of every two pairs of Adidas, sneakers are labeled made in Vietnam.
And this is funny because 10 years ago, half of Adidas,
his production was in China. The change has been very rapid.
And I know what many of you are going to tell me, let's see Josh.
That's not necessarily an improvement.
That's just swapping one sweatshop for another.
We all know the textile industry doesn't pay good wages. Look at Bangladesh.
Bangladesh is the Mecca of the fashion industry,
but they have been anchored in poverty for decades. And yes, you're right.
The textile industry is a low value added industry, but unlike Bangladesh,
Vietnam is already starting to make a technology.
Technological products certainly have added value and much higher salaries.
And you'll say made in Vietnam. What kind of technology has made in Vietnam?
Well, for starters, these gauges that many of you will be using right now.
Apple is reportedly starting to build some of its AirPods in Vietnam to give you.
In the last 10 years,
Vietnam's GDP has doubled and this extra cashflow has resulted in real
improvements for the lives of all the Vietnamese. As an example,
unlike the Chinese 97% of Vietnamese have health coverage,
it is true that wages are still low,
but it is also true that there is official protective housing and all sorts of
programs to reduce poverty
Cities like [inaudible] city or so I've gone have impressive skylines filled
with skyscrapers.
And even the slums have much better infrastructure than other countries like
Bangladesh or India. So the question is what's going on in Vietnam?
How is it possible that a country that was once at war with the United States
has integrated so well into the world's market?
How is it possible that they will benefit so greatly from the Corona virus
today? We're going to answer these questions,
but first let's look at some history.
Good morning, Vietnam.
Few walls have inspired more movies and more songs than the Vietnam war.
We've all seen apocalypse. Now we've listened to Creedence Clearwater revival.
And if you haven't,
I honestly don't know what you're doing with your life seriously. Yet.
All of that is coming from the American view of the war.
What I'm sure you don't know so well is how the Vietnamese lived during and
after the war. And believe me,
it's a much sadder story than any non movie you've already seen whilst it's true
that Vietnam won the war. The country was completely destroyed
Between 1 million and 3 million Vietnamese lost their lives.
And unlike world war II, Vietnam had no martial plan.
Obviously the U S wasn't going to help them rebuild. By that time,
the Soviet union had more important things to worry about than a country that
they hardly knew was on the map to make matters worse.
The Vietnamese government was not exactly an example of responsible management.
Oh,
men had died during the war and his success has made even Stalin looked like a
moderate politician to give you an idea within just a few years,
the Vietnamese communist party expropriated all farmland,
and it put more than 250,000 South Vietnamese in reeducation camps,
But it doesn't invent.
Many of you probably think that all communist countries get along right. Well,
you're wrong. During the 1980s, Vietnam and Cambodia went to war.
Cambodia was supported by China. Basically China ended up attacking Vietnam.
In other words, it was as if the war with the United States was not enough.
The Vietnamese suffered two Wars for the price of one. As you can imagine,
by 1986, the country was a real echo,
homo fat in hyperinflation and extreme poverty.
And that's when the communist party convened a meeting. As with China,
the younger politicians told the older ones, this.
We have made mistakes due to leftist and frontalis ism idealism.
These mistakes were manifested in maintaining the bureaucracy centralized
mechanism of economic management,
true wrong chin Vietnamese communist politician.
This is how the DOI program was born. The great Vietnamese reform.
Basically the DOJ was something similar to the opening of China,
but on steroids, unlike China, Vietnam did not make special economic zones.
They made it national. And in 10 years,
they changed the whole country from top to bottom, to give you an idea in 1986,
having a company, even if it was a family farm was forbid 10 years later,
Nike was already opening its first factories on Vietnamese soil.
And I know what you're thinking, right? We've seen this story before.
Basically it's the same thing that happened in China. Isn't it?
What makes Vietnam so special? Let's look at that right now.
Like trainer, but with low Tara.
If you have a company I want to open a factory.
Vietnam has two unbeatable advantages over China,
lower salaries and a younger population. We have already explained this.
In other videos,
the one child policy in China has resulted in a very lopsided aging society in
Vietnam. They did the opposite.
The government gave all kinds of aid for families that have many children as a
result, almost all Vietnamese are of working age. Meanwhile,
North of the border, Chinese salaries are getting higher. For example, today,
a Shinzen worker is paid equivalent to one in hungry.
So.
What usually happens in these cases? Well,
China specializes in higher value added tasks that is they start producing their
own smartphones. There are drones and their own electric cars,
things that require workers with education and the more mechanical jobs are
outsourced to Vietnam. That explains news headlines like.
This.
Yarn giant tech song to invest $500 million in Vietnam.
Exactly. The first step in Vietnam's development was to become China's China.
At this point, this was not anything that we hadn't seen in other countries.
However things changed in 2018, specifically on the 5th of July, 2018.
Trump's trade war with China is officially underway.
That's when Trump started putting tariffs on Chinese products,
China responded with more tariffs on us products. And in the meantime,
many companies that had factories on Chinese soil started to wonder,
where else could we go? And the answer was crystal clear, Vietnam.
It's right next door to China. In fact,
many companies have circumvented the U S tariffs by exporting goods from
Vietnam.
[Inaudible].
You, you're a Chinese steel producer.
If you send steel beams directly to the United States,
you have to pay a 25% tariff, but there's a loophole you can send the beans do.
Haiphong port you relabel your goods made in Vietnam and Hey Presto,
you can ship it to Los Angeles. Duty-free of course this practice,
what is known as trans shipping is beginning to be bad,
but many exporters have been taking advantage of this loophole.
[Inaudible].
Cheating aside.
There are also many legitimate businesses that are beginning to see Vietnam as
their new China. And we're not talking about shoe factories anymore.
We're talking about much more important.
Googled it.
Shift pixel smartphone production from China to Vietnam.
Of course, this is not the first smartphone factory to be set up in Vietnam.
Nakia had factories there for years, but this is just one example, Samsung,
Apple, and many other companies are already doing the same thing.
Vietnamese mobile phone brands are even emerging,
even more in their favorite is the fact that Vietnam has many political
advantages.
In a way we could say that they are in the same place that China was before
using ping arrived a country that is increasingly opening up to the world.
A communist dictatorship. Yes,
but where almost all decisions are made in a collective manner.
Or if you like.
G Jinping is China's most undisputed leader.
He has almost unlimited power in Vietnam.
There is a general secretary of the communist party, a prime minister,
a party president, and a communist assembly.
Of course they all belong to the same party,
but some are controlling the others. It's still a dictatorship,
but a much softer one than China's. And that shows.
[Inaudible].
Vietnamese. People can watch YouTube videos. Obviously many videos are censored,
but the platform is totally legal. What's more, there are Vietnamese YouTubers,
probably even this video will be able to be viewed in Vietnam.
The same goes for Facebook, Google,
and any other internet company can give you an idea.
Whilst China is increasingly protectionist, Vietnam is making deals.
It was like this.
Vietnam council gave us final green light to free trade agreements,
free trade agreement between the Eurasian economic union and Vietnam to enter
force on October 5th, 2016. But.
This was happening before the pandemic. And we promise that this video,
would it be about how Vietnam is the great beneficiary of the coronavirus?
Right. Well, right now we're going to see.
[Inaudible].
The Corona virus winners. We said it.
At the beginning of this video,
even though it's growing Vietnam is still a poor country.
If China has a per capita income of $20,000,
Vietnam is only around $8,600.
[Inaudible].
However,
the Vietnamese government has managed to ensure health coverage for 97% of the
population. Because of that, the government,
despite being a dictatorship has been very transparent with everything that it
is linked with the coronavirus from day one,
they launched all sorts of campaigns to have informed citizens why they had to
wear masks,
the correct method for washing hands and why it was important to stay at home.
Conclusion to date,
Vietnam has 334 confirmed cases of COVID-19 and zero
deaths. That's what I said. These results are impressive on their own,
but considering that they share a border with China,
they are truly worthy of applause, but we're not just talking about health.
We're also talking about economics.
Shine up. Plus one strategy could help to keep supply chains robust.
Basically if there's one thing that we've learned from the pandemic,
it's that it's not good to depend on a single country to produce things.
And we're not just talking about mobile phones. For example,
95% of the ibuprofen consumed in the United States comes from China.
It's a similar story with other things like masks.
So when something like a pandemic arrives or the production disappears into thin
air, we'll explain this further in another video, but stick with this concept,
China plus what that is. Okay. We have a supplier in China,
but we're going to have another one as a backup in another country,
just in case companies are already taking note. And so on.
Japan sets a saves 243.5 billion yen to help firms shift production
out of China.
All of this helps explain why we are seeing so many companies moving part of
their production to Vietnam in 2020, from Google to Microsoft.
If you notice we're no longer talking about Nike or Adidas. In other words,
we're no longer talking about workshops with cheap flavor.
Increasingly we are seeing technology companies,
opening factories in this region. That means better skilled, better patients.
Jobs.
Many of you were thinking, Oh my God, Vietnam is paradise.
Now all those companies that once went to China are going to go like sheep to
Vietnam. Not really, of course not in principle.
Vietnam still has a lot of problems. Think about it.
China has been the world's factory for decades.
That means that it is currently very easy to find skilled workers there.
People who have studied at universities and who know how to produce high value
added goods. In addition,
China already has luxury infrastructures and suppliers of all kinds.
Vietnam is many years away from reaching that level. And of course,
other countries like Thailand now also have an opportunity to join the trend.
And other words,
Vietnam needs to invest much more in education and building roads. Moreover,
we must not forget that the country is still a dictatorship with all the
political risks that this entails.
But right now we can say that while almost every nation is facing a recession,
Vietnam is one of the few exceptions and we'll continue to do.
So.
Christian is over to you. Is this going to be Vietnam's decade?
How long will it take before we see Vietnamese tourists walking through our
cities, can Vietnam become a democracy or will they follow in China's footsteps?
You can leave me your answer in the comments. And as always,
don't forget that we upload new videos every week.
So subscribe to visual politic and make sure that you don't miss any of our
updates. Also,
this channel is possible because of Patrion and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage out. Of course, if you liked this video, give it a like,
and I'll see you in.
The next one.